[Music]
it now gives me great pleasure to
welcome the 16th president of MIT dr.
Susan Hockfield she will give some
remarks and proceed to introduce our
keynote speaker jerry hudson president
Hockfield
[Applause]
Thank You Richie it's some good morning
yeah you know what can I do to follow
this amazing amazing program I'd say you
know there is no better way I can't
imagine a better way to greet the new
day than soaring on the wings of the MIT
gospel choir and Jermaine thank you very
much for waking us all up to the day and
it's great potential
I also want to thank dylon and Zenzi I
am so proud of both of you
dialing you really called out to all of
us you know it seems to me almost every
week that I'm good at my tea our motto
mends at Menace means more and more but
you really called out for us how theory
is great but alone it is just
insufficient until it's reduced to
practice and it really sits at the heart
of MIT and not every place not every
institution of higher education and
Zenzi your exhortation for us to not
only be thankful for our gifts but to
use them with a sense of really joyful
responsibility it's just so wonderful
what a great call to action we are
incredibly blessed to have the two of
you with your intellect and insight and
joy to be part of this community so
thank you very very much actually would
you join me in thanking them
I also want to thank our hosts this
morning the Committee on race and
diversity this breakfast is only part of
the work that they do on campus frankly
all the time every week every month to
be sure that these issues of race and
diversity stay in the front of our focus
and keep our minds on the work that yet
remains to be done to make this campus
the place that we know it can be on the
annual calendar this annual celebration
of the legacy of the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King jr. is an important moment
its annually an important moment for
coming together for finding fresh
inspiration which we receive in bucket
loads every year at this breakfast it's
great to be here again but on that
reflection about sources of inspiration
I have to comment for a second on the
dedication of this morning's breakfast
to leo Osgood I want to take a moment to
acknowledge that with his passing last
November MIT really lost one of our most
important and enduring sources of
inspiration over nearly his three
decades at the Institute
Leo Osgood made innumerable
contributions as a professor as a coach
as the Dean on call for what was then
called the office of the Dean for
student affairs as a friend as a mentor
as a counselor and certainly as a
comfort to generations of students among
his many contributions and I have to say
this is just a very small list of much
much longer list let me just call out
his leadership in conceiving and
initiating the Martin Luther King jr.
visiting Scholars Program and we
celebrated the visitors this year
welcome to MIT glad to have you on
campus his seminal contributions to
project interphase that has benefited so
many students at MIT his work as
co-chair of a Presidential Task Force on
the career development of
underrepresented minority administrators
something we continue to take very
seriously and all his work as associate
dean and director of the Office of
minority education he led that program
from 1995 until he retired in 2006 Leo
was a guiding force behind this
celebration for many
years and we are all very much the
beneficiaries of his compassionate
vision now dylon and Zenzi have both
testified eloquently to the importance
of the theme this morning deploying our
gifts to the greater good and we're
gonna hear more on this theme from our
keynote speaker jerry hudson so i want
to just take my time to focus on two
ways that this idea of deploying our
gifts intersects with the life and work
of MIT as Enzi described at MIT is a
gift in itself and one that we each of
us has a duty to use in service to the
world yet as wonderful as the gift of
MIT may be intrinsic to its value and
intrinsic to our understanding its value
is a perpetual striving to be ever
better this is woven into the very
fabric of the life at MIT this is a very
important piece of our mission and an
important and constructive tool to help
us build to a stronger MIT is the recent
report from the initiative on faculty
race and diversity I have to acknowledge
the scale and scope of the effort which
under the leadership of Professor Paula
Hammond the bayar professor of chemical
engineering involved 8 MIT faculty
members who worked over a period of two
and a half years they conducted
extensive quantitative and qualitative
research and the report has many many
important observations but it
demonstrated among other things that
through the search and tenure process
and in their daily lives on campus the
experience of many of our faculty
members from underrepresented minority
groups is different from that of their
majority peers and sometimes that
difference is painfully obvious clearly
to achieve a true culture of inclusion
the topic on which I have spoken
annually about and you know my passion
about this to make MIT as valuable and
effective as it can be we still have
much work to do
fortunately the report from this task
force recommends the kind of practical
steps that
can accelerate positive change they
don't just talk about things in theory
they think talk about things in practice
for example it makes a makes it clear
that strong mentoring for junior faculty
makes a tremendous difference and yet it
finds that mentoring is a bit uneven
across the Institute now once MIT has
succeeded in recruiting brilliant young
faculty members to our campus it only
makes sense that we would give them the
guidance that enables them to thrive
here getting that process right will
contribute directly to the excellence of
MIT I want to quote now from someone who
already has taken direct positive direct
personal responsibility for creating a
culture of inclusion professor ed
Bertschinger who's here this morning I
saw him there he is who now heads the
department of physics for those of you
who have not yet seen our new diversity
website please check it out it's very
exciting and I'm going to quote from his
blog on that website he says I am
sometimes asked why do you do this why
do I spend time and energy promoting
diversity and inclusion at MIT and in my
profession two reasons the first is an
intrinsic sense of fairness and justice
and second the key to turning idealism
into effective action is that I learned
how to be effective by mentoring junior
faculty starting almost a decade ago mit
attracts great talent but does not
always nurture that talent very well a
sink or swim environment will separate
individuals but can be terribly wasteful
of human potential and is generally
harmful to morale good mentoring is at
least as important as a financially
adequate startup package for new faculty
members I would like it if we considered
mentoring an essential part of the
startup package for new faculty and
we're going to work on that as the first
step in implementing the new reports
recommendations Provost Rafael rife and
professor Hammond have already begun
strategy meetings with academic council
with school councils and the heads of
academic units to translate the report's
recommendations into actions on the
ground we'll begin by sharing best
practices around faculty searches
recruitment and mentorship there are
places where these things are done well
and it's important that those places
where it's done well share of their
practices across the Institute so that
in ed Bertschinger is phrase people can
learn how to be effective in creating
change in broader terms I also hope that
the findings of this report will help
make it easier for individuals and
departments to think and talk openly
about issues of race and how those
issues affect them because I believe on
this score we really do have a lot of
work to do since the report came out
though I have to be honest and direct
with you all I've heard from a number of
people that its findings and
recommendations might somehow threaten
to erode or compromise the excellence of
MIT I could not disagree more as I've
said many times MIT is and always must
be a place with unrelenting standards of
excellence this report is not about
compromising those standards it's about
reaching them for almost 150 years mit
has built and maintained its standards
of excellence by bringing in the very
best people and offering them an
environment where they can do their very
best work thanks to the initiative on
faculty race and diversity we have new
information that will allow us to uphold
these bedrock MIT standards and
strengthening MIT and this dimension is
pivotal to helping us magnify and deploy
our shared gifts for humankind that idea
is not simply the theme of the
celebration today it's at the heart of
the mission of MIT every day the people
of MIT in profound ways deliver on our
mission to advance knowledge and educate
students in science technology and other
areas of scholarship to serve the nation
and the world every day they use their
exceptional powers of analysis and
creativity to tackle some of humanity's
greatest challenges from sustainable
energy to drinkable water from cancer to
autism to AIDS from the shape of our
cities to the future of our oceans and
so I'm pleased but not at all surprised
to note that people are indeed using
their gifts to respond to
the terrible human tragedy that
continues to unfold still in Haiti and
Island thank you very much for calling
this out as he mentioned many many of
our students are donating time and
talent as well as money mi t--'s public
service center is coordinating a range
of efforts to channel funds and
expertise to Haiti and thanks to the
work of two of our dedicated researchers
Chris Csikszentmihalyi in Dale Holcomb
since the earthquake people and in
connected with the Media Lab have used
their technological skills and
creativity to facilitate communication
between Haitians here and in Haiti and
they plan to extend their work through
the very long rebuilding process to help
match the flow of resources to the
actual areas of need now I have to tell
you I know of many of the efforts on
campus to reach into Haiti to help in
whatever we can but I am absolutely
certain that I don't know of all of them
if any of you know of things that I
haven't yet mentioned and would like us
to be aware of them please don't
hesitate to just shoot me an email so
that we can add those activities to the
growing list of efforts from MIT to help
build rebuild Haiti let me close with a
passage that bears special consideration
for those of us who belong to an
intellectual community like MIT its
drawn from dr. King's Nobel Prize
lecture the quest for peace and justice
that was written almost a half-century
ago to many of us here in the audience
that feels like only yesterday but to
others in the audience it seems like an
eternity ago separating the younger part
of our MIT population from the older
part as dr. King framed it modern man
has brought this whole world to an
awe-inspiring threshold of the future he
has reached new and astonishing peaks of
scientific success he has produced
machines that think and instruments that
peer into the unfathomable ranges of
interstellar space he has built gigantic
bridges to span the Seas and gargantuan
buildings to kiss the skies his
airplanes and spaceships have dwarfed
distant
place time in Chains and carved highways
through the stratosphere this is a
dazzling picture of modern man
scientific and technological progress
yet in spite of these spectacular
strides in science and technology the
richer we have become materially the
poorer we have become morally and
spiritually we have learned to fly the
air like birds and swim the sea like
fish but we have not learned the simple
art of living together as brothers in
many ways in many places dr. King's
words still ring true the human family
has certainly not yet mastered the art
of living together but I hope that
perhaps we've learned something about
the true human purposes of Technology
and I'm extremely proud to be part of a
community that is harnessing the tools
of modern technology and science to
serve the highest human purposes of
connection compassion and kindness and
thank you all for joining me on that
mission
now for what I know I've been waiting
for since I woke up very early this
morning it's my very great pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker Gerald
Hudson he's executive vice president of
the Service Employees International
Union SEIU with more than 2.2 million
members SEIU is North America's fastest
growing labor union and Jerry Hudson has
focused his attention on advancing the
interests of those who work with the
elderly and disabled in long-term care a
member of SEIU since 1978 Gerry has also
made his mark with an ambitious
commitment to combining social justice
with environmental activism he was part
of the first ever US Labor delegation to
the United Nations climate change
meeting in Bali in 2007 focusing on the
disproportionate impacts of
environmental degradation on low-income
and minority communities he served on
the advisory board of the Apollo
Alliance a labor based organization that
promotes ways to create high quality
jobs in clean energy economies and he
served on the board of redefining
progress a leading think-tank creating
innovative public policies that balance
economic well-being environmental
preservation and social justice this
morning he's going to talk to us about
one of his ongoing efforts an initiative
he co-founded with MIT professor Phil
Thompson called emerald cities something
I know a little bit about and it's very
exciting so I'm delighted that we're
going to get an additional insight into
that this morning ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming Jerry Hudson
[Applause]
Wow these are some tough acts to follow
it's hard to inspire you when you
inspire me so so let's begin I want to
start by thanking president Hockfield
Provost Reif Chancellor clay and the
Subcommittee on diversity race and
diversity for organizing this event I
want to also thank this institution
because whether you know it or not I've
made enormous use of this institution
for at least the last five or six years
so I wanna 1 thank you because you went
with me and some other labor leaders in
to New Orleans right after Katrina where
we thought that there were to be more of
a labor response to what was going on
there and that the whole of the labor
movement really ought to look not to
just responding to the call for relief
but also to respond by in some ways
staying the course in trying to
reconstruct that city and so with Phil
Thompson a whole team of MIT professors
and students went in to New Orleans
and we began to build a proposal for
rehabilitating the public housing in New
Orleans that proposal was so admired and
respected by the labor movement at the
time that the afl-cio pledged to give a
billion dollars out of its pension funds
to reconstruct public housing in Haiti
that was a labor movement that made a
commitment that I was proud of the
problem is that when we in fact made the
proposal we had a president named Bush
who said I'd rather tear the buildings
down then allow you to rebuild them and
invite back the residents of the public
housing and so he turned us down billion
dollars and all but still you this
institution it's faculty and students
were there on the ground and some of
them remain on the ground in New Orleans
to this day when I thought that it might
be a good idea to try to force again
this labor movement of which I've spent
in which I've spent the better part of
my working life to rethink its notion of
leadership and to rethink how it did its
work on the ground
connecting ordinary workers to each
other I also came back to MIT and found
my friend Otto Sharma and we spent quite
a bit of time talking about the
reinvention of the
leadership for the 21st century so thank
you
Otto for that Thanks
Sloane Center for its work and then
again when I started emerald cities and
we weren't quite sure how we wanted to
get emerald cities moving in the world
we had a lot of great and interesting
people from the labor movement people
from communities of color all around the
country we had them all in one place but
we weren't quite sure how best to use
them and so I asked stuck Tom kokin to
help me facilitate a meeting of that
first retreat on green jobs right here
at MIT and so I thank you Tom for that
great work so I guess you can tell that
MIT is one of those places where I come
to do what the philosopher novelists
Albert Camus says find a respite from
using I find you great partners in the
act of using musing about great problems
of the world and trying to find
solutions to those problems I always
find big hearts and open mine in eager
spirits here at MIT and so I'm
exceedingly grateful and the institution
that I lead is exceedingly grateful to
the leadership the students and the
faculty of MIT dr. King
I had a lot of remarks and I wanted to
make about King King is my amuse King is
the reason why I chose to be an
organizer if you know anything about the
institution that I come from you know
that that institution is called 1199 in
New York and if you walk through the
doors of 1199 in New York as you come to
the through the door and you look to
your left there's a bus of dr. King and
under it there's a quote from King and
over it there's a big picture of King
talking and in 1199 rally dr. king
called $11.99 his favorite union it is
the union that my mother when she moved
from the south as a domestic she joined
as a nursing home worker in New York it
is a union that has had a long tradition
of combining social justice with the
fight for economic justice it is a union
that understands that that is an odd
bifurcation social and economic justice
that the only way in which you can in
fact do anything about economic justice
is if you do something about social
justice king-like vision the vision 1199
from its inception as a hospital workers
union in New York it is the union that
was one of four unions that actually
supported dr. King in his call for a
march on Washington
so you know for me there's a union that
I am deeply proud of and then one of the
proudest moments of my life is when I
was given the opportunity to serve that
Union and I served it for 20 years as
its political director its
communications director and its
education director dr. King my muse I
want to tell you that mostly nowadays I
don't do celebrations for King I stopped
doing them a couple of years back
because I could hardly recognize the
king that I knew in love whose writings
I had read I could hardly recognize him
and much of the speeches that were given
about him in some of these celebrations
and the only reason that I chose to come
here to this celebration of King is
because I think you get it to get the
real King message the real King message
and so I want to talk to you about that
message it's a message that if you go
back in the writings of King one of the
most interesting places to stop there's
a speech that he gave in 1961 it's
really quote it really talked about but
it was a speech given before the afl-cio
it's interesting what prompted the
speech because four years inside of the
afl-cio there was a grand old gentleman
named a Phillip Randolph we'd been
working inside of the
FL CIO and insisting that the afl-cio
deal with the question of diversity deal
with the question of race and racial
discrimination in the labor movement he
had been working and toiling on that
issue for some 25 years by the time King
gave the speech that he gave if you
remember that 61 is six years after
Montgomery it's two years before the
march on Washington and he gave a speech
that was suggestively entitled when the
Negro wins labor wins the reverse is
also true and he suggested it in that
speech if the lead role loses labour
will lose he suggested that in that
speech what he was about was not just an
opposition to white supremacy and racism
in America that what he was truly
against was war poverty that we would
achieve the good Society the just
society when we rid the world of war and
poverty and that civil right the
achievement of civil rights was merely a
means to the building of the right kind
of movement that could in fact rid the
world of poverty and war that was the
king that spoke before the afl-cio and
he then implored them to come with him
on a journey through the south
to eliminate white supremacy and to use
the victory over white supremacy in the
south as a jump-off point for creating a
coalition of conscience I should tell
you that Meany who led the afl-cio at
the time and most of the affiliates of
the afl-cio did not heed Martin Luther
King's call the Negro was asked to go
off and to fight Jim Crow on its own
without Labor's support he left that
convention and he made a trek around the
country talking to unions everywhere and
in union halls everywhere convinced that
a Negro as he put it
Negro labor alliance was fundamental to
creating a progressive politics in the
country and he invited them to join him
on the march on Washington demanding and
into Jim Crow and people forget this it
was freedom and jobs freedom and jobs
was not just about civil rights but it
was about economic justice as well
freedom in jobs come with me sad to say
that of all the unions of the afl-cio
only four only four or will then
to take that journey I start with that
King because I think the failure of a
labor movement to see the cause of black
folks demanding and into white supremacy
and demanding economic justice in
America the failure of a labor movement
to join with that movement is what gave
rise to an ugly politics that has swept
this country for more than 40 years
because if you remember that right after
we got the voter Rights Act and the
Civil Rights Act Civil Rights Act of 64
the Voting Rights Act of 65 something
really interesting happen in the country
rather than the labor movement and
everybody joining with black folks and
trying to use the franchise and trying
to use it in a way to bring about a
progressive politics in the country
instead dixiecrats started to flee the
Democratic Party and droves and by the
time you get to 68 when King was
murdered an interesting man that King
used to encounter in the South was
moving all about the country picking up
supporters everywhere those of you who
are as old as I am will remember that
that man was George Wallace he met him
as governor of Alabama and by 68
governor Wallace was running for
president and picking up supporters in
places that were interesting Democratic
strongholds
Michigan Pennsylvania Ohio suddenly they
were supporting governor Wallace and if
you go back to that year you know that
the Democrats for the first time in a
long time
lost the president see the United States
and Nixon was elected and I would submit
to you the long nightmare of American
politics begins there I see it it's the
failure of all those places because what
makes Pennsylvania interesting what
makes Michigan interesting
what makes Massachusetts interesting is
they were strongholds of the labor
movement and all of that white
working-class movements went one way in
reaction to the victory of black people
in the south and Republicans came to
power and began a nightmare politics
that lasted 40 years when the Negro
loses labor losses and if you think
about these past 40 or so years you will
also remember that the labor movement
went in decline at the beginning of the
period when King was making his call
labor was some 33% union density in the
country as a whole at the end of this
nightmarish politics union density in
this country
is now a 12% a 12% with private sector
Union density at seven-and-a-half
percent if the trends continue there
will be no labor movement in 20 years in
the country and with the labor movement
has also gone in come where we now are
the most outrageous concentration of
wealth in the history of the country
with the top 1% owning as much as 34
percent of the nation's wealth
outrageous inequality outrageous
inequality presided over by a right-wing
Republican politic that was created I
would say way way back when Labour
refused to join hands with the Negro and
start the trek towards the creation of
what was truly Martin's dream which was
to create a world in which every human
being no matter who they are had a right
to flourish had a right to flourish and
he believed that it could only be
brought about
go check the text that text that I
reference and I would suggest real good
sort of look at the vision go check
another tax it was where do we go from
here
chaos or community chaos or community
because in that text you see him
struggling with how it is that we not
only deal with white supremacy and then
move on to deal with poverty and war in
this country but have him doing it in
the rest of the world and he ends the
book with a long conversation about the
world house science has now made a
smaller and more interdependent he said
that requires that we learn to live
together in some new way president you
had a wonderful Pope because he
suggested that while we made all this
progress in science we had made two
little progress in matters of the heart
and had not yet known as a people to
live together I say this is a timely
moment to remember that King that came
because it was that king that was most
recently invoked again if you go back to
2008 to Colorado
and you remember Barack Obama acceptance
of the nomination of the Democratic
Party that whole acceptance speech was
prepared by a recollection thing the
whole thing he brought King's children
on stage he made all kinds of references
to King it was almost like a passing of
the baton I've often said to Phil
Thompson one of my dearest friends that
when Martin's
generation passed the baton to us having
dismantled Jim Crow having put a vision
out there I was worried that we dropped
it that we had dropped the baton at a
crucial moment when we should be
advancing but on that stage with Barack
Obama in 2008 I was persuaded that maybe
just maybe our generation had picked up
the baton and that we might for the
first time given all of what was in that
stadium young people all over the
country of all races all in there having
worked their tails off to get to that
moment with Barack Obama labor movements
who had fought themselves argued among
themselves for months but finally
together in that stadium celebrating
this man who said I will create a
politics
of hope to fight against the politics of
division and fear and hate that is rule
the country thus far I will bring into
existence of politics of change that you
can believe in it was a remarkable
passing of the baton one year later
one year later
I'm worried about that doll instead of
hope that was so eloquently spoken about
on the stage in a stadium in Colorado
I'm worried about it we promise changed
the change didn't come and you and
Massachusetts know a little bit about
the why of it but what I've learned in
this year where all of the great issues
of my life from health care reform to
green jobs to labor law reform all of
these things that I've struggled that I
thought were essential plants and a
progressive platform all of these things
were on the national scene a president
can't bring those things about he didn't
want them he can ask for them but he
can't make them happen that takes you
that takes me that takes all of us there
will be no change in America we will not
create a more just America in which
wealth is more equitably distributed in
which every child no matter who or where
they are in this country can flourish
and use all of the gifts that they have
there will be no change that brings that
America about unless you use your gifts
put your gifts back on the field
I believe having spent 20 years with the
members of my own Union in the
incredible ability of ordinary men and
women to move mountains I've watched my
Union do incredible things when they
decide to collectively put their
shoulder to the wheel so I say to you in
my tea we need your gifts put out there
one more time to try to realize the
possibility of a more just America it
will not happen unless you put your
gifts on the table and knowing what I
know about yes in this room if you put
them on the table we'll get there
thank you so much Oh
[Applause]